have you ever wondered what cartoon
animals would look like as people they
all come with such unique personalities
it's hard to believe they aren't
actually human just wait until you see a
human version of Simba don't forget to
subscribe to the thing and give this
video a thumbs up today we're checking
out 10 cartoon animals reimagined as
people Lady and the [ __ ] can you
believe it's been more than 60 years
since Lady and the [ __ ] was released
this Disney classic is still just as
popular as it was after its release the
story is about an uptown cocker spaniel
who falls madly in love with a downtown
month the movie took 20 years to create
but we're glad Disney took their time
did you know that they almost cut out
the spaghetti eating scene imagine what
a mistake that would be have you ever
wondered what the characters from Lady
and the [ __ ] would look like if they
were actual people this talented teen
artist who goes by the name of Elena
Bastian decided to transform cartoon
animals into real-life humans and we're
very impressed with this version of Lady
and the [ __ ] lady's long cocker spaniel
fur looks amazing we love how the artist
kept the characters original colors what
do you think about tramps grey hair we
can't get over these two it's still one
of the best love stories we ever heard
of and it looks like the human versions
of lady in the [ __ ] are just as happily
in love the classic Disney story taught
us a very important life lesson that you
can find love at some of the most
unexpected places of your life there
right because we're in love with this
illustration Timon Pumbaa and Simba
Hakuna Matata what a wonderful phrase if
Lion King is your favorite movie
you'll love this illustration Timon
Pumbaa
and Simba have great chemistry during
the film but imagine how their
friendship would look like if they were
actual humans this deviantART user chain
showed off her skills and recreated a
human version of The Lion King trio
let's have a closer look shall we
Simba is the smallest one of the bunch
with ginger hair and quite a lot of
muscles and is that a tail we see in the
background he does seem to fit the
description of the original Simba and
then there's Timon the energetic meerkat
who sometimes just a little bit to self
centric this human version of Timon is
certainly giving us that meerkat smile
and we love his two ear piercings and
speaking of facial features Pumbaa
is rocking that mustache and let's not
forget about his amazing hair that's
shaved on one side it looks like the
Lion King
trio of outcasts didn't just become
human they also became extremely modern
we'd love to see a human version of Nala
did you know that the creators of the
Lion King revealed that knowledge father
might be scar or even Mufasa now that
would be a very interesting addition to
the original Hawaiian King storyline
Sebastian from The Little Mermaid and
who can forget about the Little Mermaid
crab who completely stole every scene of
the movie
Sebastian is one of those characters you
just can't help but love they remind us
not to take life too seriously and burst
out into a happy song instead Sebastian
is a red Jamaican crab who's usually
carefree when he's not worried about
Ariel he's got an interesting
personality and we're very intrigued how
it would play out if he were human well
a tumblr user pug Leto created a series
of photos showcasing a realistic version
of cartoon characters and since
Sebastian ranks pretty high on our
favorite Disney character list we
thought we'd show you what he'd look
like in real life we are totally in love
with this illustration human Sebastian
replaced his red skin with red hair and
he gay
some muscles this version of Sebastian
would be a game-changer in the Little
Mermaid story speaking of the Little
Mermaid have you ever noticed that
characters from other Disney movies make
an appearance in several scenes some say
you can spot Donald Duck goofy and
Mickey memos at the beginning of the
movie we're not quite done with
reimagining the Little Mermaid
characters wait until you see what the
next Disney favorite looks like in real
life Arielle and flounder this design
was done by the same artist who drew the
lion Kings Timon Simba and Pumbaa so you
can imagine how amazing it's going to be
meets the human version of flounder
everyone's favorite tropical fish
flounder gets easily worried but who
wouldn't when you're friends with the
stubborn Ariel he has a striking look
with his yellow body and blue fins
although we can't see the colors of this
drawing we can imagine the human version
of flounder would wear colorful clothing
as possibly blond or blue hair we love
how smiley flounder looks on this
picture did you know that flounder isn't
a flounder fish in fact this is how an
actual this kind of fish looks like we
can't imagine our flounder being
completely flat like that but it would
sure add a comical effect of the story
if you're looking to see more human
versions of the Little Mermaid you might
be in for a treat
Disney announced a live-action remake of
the popular classic the movie is still
in the early works but we can't wait to
see who will get to play our favorite
characters BuzzFeed is betting on Selena
Gomez's Ariel and gotten Motta's ro as
flounder Baloo and Bagheera from the
Jungle Book
remember the jungle book the animated
version of Rudyard Kipling's children's
book was released in 1967 and the movie
adaptation appeared in 2016 the story
went through quite a few visual changes
but the characters of the jungle book
will always remain the same some of the
favorites include Baloo and
era a bear and a black panther who are
caring and loving toward Mowgli for
those who aren't familiar with the story
Bagheera is the one who finds Mowgli as
a baby and Baloo saves him the three
have a strong bond and only want what's
best for each other
this illustration was done by a tumblr
user called pug Leto did you know that
Disney movies have a long history of
characters that assumingly belonged to
the LGBT community and Bagheera and
Baloo are definitely not the only
characters who made that list they often
act more like a married couple rather
than just friends and many Disney fans
love the idea that some of these
characters might be a part of the LGBT
community we love the human version of
the two they both still show their
unique caring personalities and you
can't even spot Baloo's goofy side all
we want to hear now is the human Baloo's
version of the bare necessities song
duchess and thomas o'malley from the
Aristocats on a scale of one to ten how
much do you love the Aristocats this
animated classic is more than 40 years
old and it was first released in 1970
the story follows abandoned cats that
are trying to return home the main
characters of the movie are Duchess and
Thomas O'Malley Duchess is a white
Turkish Angora cat who is very elegant
and ladylike while Thomas is more
streetwise naturally the two end up
falling in love
Elena Bastian illustrated the two cats
in a human form and we have to say that
this looks like a very accurate
representation of the two Duchess is
dressed in all white and has that
elegant hair and fancy dress while
Thomas O'Malley has a snazzy hat and
slightly less elegant clothes
the original Thomas has orange fur and
the enchanting human version kept the
orange color in his hair did you know
that the Aristocats was one of the first
disney movies that had more focus on
story development and in-depth
characters it took 35 animators for
years to create this amazing story and
we're very grateful for its success I
guess the eristic
that's title we'll have to get changed
into Aristo humans to make this version
of duchess and thomas o'malley work but
it would still make for an interesting
story spongebob and patrick who lives in
a pineapple under the sea
SpongeBob SquarePants and it is even
better when his friend Patrick comes to
visit him the two BFFs are inseparable
and they've been entertaining us for
years did you know that the creator of
the show was a marine biologist who
would have thought that you can combine
marine biology and animation and create
something as popular as SpongeBob
SquarePants do you have a favorite
moment from the Spongebob our favorite
has to be the episode where SpongeBob
and Patrick sell chocolate to their
neighbors this duo brought us some of
the most entertaining moments in cartoon
history although SpongeBob's technically
not an animal we've decided to include
him in this video and show you what he
would look like as a person and here
they are the humanized duo this design
belongs to a deviantART user called
Souza Murray and we have to say we're
very impressed with how realistic it is
everyone's favorite sponge now turned
into a teenage boy with blond hair and a
slightly obese starfish best friend is
now a full-grown person did you know
that according to SpongeBob's driving
license his birthday is July 14th 1986
which means he's in his 30s although
based on their personalities and a
carefree attitude to life we prefer the
teenage version of these two dory Marlon
and Nemo
but SpongeBob and Patrick aren't the
only sea creatures that manage to take
over the world with their personalities
and their stories Finding Nemo is one of
the most beloved Disney movies following
the story of a dad called Marlin who
tries very hard to protect his child
Nemo but ultimately fails when Nemo gets
taken by the fisherman the story talks
about the importance of getting out of
your comfort zone and the fact that your
differences do not define you Finding
Nemo shows some of Disney's most
so-called flawed but still lovable
characters so let's see
what those characters would look like in
human form this image belongs to a
talented deviantART artist nan Meena on
the Left we have a blond-haired dory
then Marvin and his son Nemo they really
do look similar to their cartoon
characters don't they
although to be honest we did expect
Marvin to look just a little bit older
Nemo on the other hand looks just as
playful and daring as he does in the
movie did you know that Finding Nemo
gives a shout out to another Disney
classic if you look close enough you can
spot Buzz Lightyear on the floor of the
dentist office now that we've seen what
the Finding Nemo trio
would look like as people we'd love to
see what Darla would look like as a fish
bolt one of the movies that we haven't
talked about much is both the 2008
Disney movie features a bunch of
exciting actors such as John Travolta
and even Miley Cyrus the story talks
about a dog who believes he has
superpowers and that he has to save
penny his owner like any dog out there
bolt is incredibly trustworthy and loyal
to those who treat him well he has a
special bond with Penny and the director
of the movie made sure they highlight
the connection between dogs and their
owners here's what bolt would look like
if he ever became a real person
this illustration belongs to a
deviantART user so Elaina a human
version of bolt features white hair with
black streaks and a similar black and
white shirt to highlight his original
look we love that the artist kept his
big curious eyes and we wondered if this
bolt would be just as heroic and curious
speaking of bolt characters did you know
that the animators brought a hamster
ball in the studio and rolled it around
to relieve stress and figure out rhino's
movements that's definitely one
character we don't want to see in a
human shape because let's face it no one
wants to see a person in a hamster ball
Simba from The Lion King we've had a
quick look at Timon Pumbaa and Simba
earlier but now let's look at what Simba
would look like as a human in more
detail Simba is a happy and carefree
youngster who grows up to take his
carefree lifestyle a little bit too
seriously and blames everything he does
wrong on someone else through the story
this eventually changes and Simba's
character develops into a real future
king of his land and his pride so what
would he look like as a human this
illustration belongs to Elena Bastian
who is just so talented we can't get
enough of her pictures the human version
of Simba has brown dreadlocks and red
coloring around his neck this version of
Simba makes us wonder what it looked
like as a child here's an unsettling
Lion King fact for you a fan theory
states that because all lionesses are
related in a pride which means that Nala
might as well be Simba's sister or
cousin now combine that with the
previous fact of Nala being scars
daughter and you get a whole nother
perspective we'd love to hear more about
do you have any crazy Lion King theories
of your own don't forget to like this
video and give it a big thumbs up for
more cartoon facts make sure to watch
ten kids cartoon characters reimagined
as people see you next time